bonsoir gérard merci d'être avec nous
tout d'abord qu'on doit tant que doit
temps d'attendre des nouvelles
négociations qui se passe à moscou en ce
moment un début de début de convergence
entre effectivement le pouvoir actuel
arts à kaboul
d'autre part les talibans et
troisièmement donc les représentants
américains et aussi de l'otan il y a ne
l'oublions pas trois fois plus de
soldats de l'otan que deux soldats
purement américain à eau en afghanistan
donc assez là le le but et il ya un
triple des filles dans cette situation
là il y a un défi intérieur pour la
stabilité en afghanistan
il y a un défi aussi extérieure parce
que un afghanistan instable aurait des
répercussions sur les voisins directs
genre pakistan ou bien un peu plus
éloigné la russie à qui à 15 % de sa
population est musulmane est aussi dans
le sud à des territoires qui sont très
très à jeudi restent sensibles à une
islamisation grandissante
donc il ya deux défis ici le troisième
c'est à l'intérieur de la société
afghane et ellien effectivement un peu
une rivalité entre ville et campagne
campagne conservatrice villes qui ont
donné un peu plus de liberté où la femme
a eu d'autres opportunités d'étudier et
de travailler
donc il ya il y a un défi à l'intérieur
de la société auxquels s'ajoute
l'arrivée de l'état islamique
alors l'état islamique précisément les
états unis annoncent qu'ils vont retirer
leurs troupes même sera difficile sera
difficile
de le faire d'ici le 1er mai un joe
biden l'a annoncé quel serait l'impact
justement de ce retrait des troupes
américaines concernant le retour de nice
féministe le de l'islamisme et des
dialyses sur place donc les troupes
américaines sont mêmes celles de l'otan
incluse ne représente qu'une fraction
des forces de sécurité en afghanistan
par rapport à la police afghane et à
l'armée afghanes donc tout ne peut pas
dépendre d'eux au contraire à tous des
propos sur les épaules des forces
intérieures afghane
et c'est bien là le défi est ce que ses
forces la voix est à même de combattre à
la fois les talibans et aussi l'état
islamique qui posait un problème
politique à aux talibans car les
talibans avant l'arrivée de l'état
islamique était la partie la plus
radicale de la société afghane
maintenant qu'il y à naissance de l'état
islamique en afghanistan et bien les
talibans sont un petit peu si je puis
dire centralisés sont dans la géométrie
politique a mis un peu au centre par
rapport à une aile extrémiste et de
l'autre côté le gouvernement donc il y à
une géométrie politique aussi
intéressante et nouvelles a observé
est-ce que ça passera par l'instauration
d'un gouvernement provisoire
c'est ce qui est demandé c'est ce qui
est souhaitable qu'elle conçoit après
les évolutions il ya effectivement la
nécessité de mettre en place une
nouvelle constitution est d'avoir une
ratification populaire et démocratique
donc c'est hautement souhaitable mais là
on est dans le jeu tactique 1 n'est ce
pas les talibans n'ayant pas arrêté les
attentats le pouvoir en place
refusant à un partage de ce pouvoir
on sent qu'on est dans la dernière ligne
droite des négociations et donc tout le
monde peuvent pousser un petit peu à la
surenchère de l'autre partie dans ces
négociations il ya un grand absent c'est
l'otan qui est pourtant présente sur le
terrain d'opération
afghan comment expliquez vous cette
absence disons que nous sommes le temps
était présent en tant que force de de
formation de l'armée afghane des forces
de sécurité afghanes n'y a pas une
présence en termes vraiment politique
n'est ce pas c'est vraiment la
représentation américaine qui joue ce
rôle là et donc depuis le début de la
situation en afghanistan depuis 2003
donc c'est une situation acquise dans
cette structure où les états unis sont
effectivement le leader de cette
activité un militaire et politique
merci beaucoup et gérard respire analyse
géopolitique chercheur associé à la fée
mots nous avoir apporté votre analyse ce
soir